Well, these two pro-Ukrainian, anti-Putin
paramilitary groups
carried out attacks on Russian
soil this week.
Now, one, that
their operations are far from over.
They've returned to Ukraine
after claiming success
in these military
raids in western Russia.
They say the raid was only one
step in a big operation,
which is ongoing.
CNN's Sam Kiley has details
It is a propaganda coup.
Russian dissident
soldiers back from a raid inside Russia,
parading a captured Russian vehicle
for the world.
What do you
hope will be the effect of this raid
effect of this?
It was amazing.
It was information of shell
information, bomb blowing about to
this whole Internet, blowing up,
boiling
the Legion and the far right
Russian volunteer corps.
All Russian
nationals are part of Ukraine's
security forces
and carry Ukrainian military IDs
This incursion into Russian territory,
which these guys say is ongoing,
was as much a propaganda mission
as it was a military mission.
But they say
it was also done
independently of the Ukrainian military.
That is a claim
we have to take with a big pinch of salt.
They jointly raided Russian territory
this week
and flooded the Internet
with images of their work.
Russia claims to have driven them out.
Still, the raid has rattled Moscow.
Do you think this is part of the coming
summer offensive, an attempt
to keep the Russians off-balance,
keep them guessing?
I think it's it's kind of yes.
Yes, it's kind of it and their cafeteria.
American-Made vehicles appear
to have been used
in the cross-border operation
in Belgorod Province.
It's unclear if they were us donations.
The vehicles that you took included
some of the American MRAPs.
Is that right that you were using?
Will you tell me also will we buy them in
international shops workshops?
Yeah.
So you bought these vehicles on the open
market? Yeah, of course.
Every everyone who have some money
can do it.
According to Ukraine's government,
which has received U.S.
vehicles and lethal hardware,
says that these men operated inside
Russia privately.
But a security source said here
that Kiev had advance knowledge
of the raid,
and Caesar admitted
Ukraine helped out with supplies
small arms,
artillery, weapons,
heavy vehicles, everything what we need.
So this was a raid
that the government can deny,
but still enjoy the results.
Divisions in the ranks of their enemies.
Mercenary leader Yevgeny
Ghosn immediately reacting with fury
following the putting.
Their egos of shit is not good enough.
See the way we do not done because
of the theater
that the got interesting muscles.
After every apocalypse,
we'll get one minority to build
that exclusive symbol up on the set.
So we managed to get our hands.
And the far right
leader of the Russian volunteer
he even warned that Moscow
could face a revolution.
The operation is ongoing.
This is how I should put it.
To be honest.
It definitely has various phases
So phase one,
we consider it a successful phase.
It's over now,
but the operation is ongoing.
That's what I can say for now.
Sam Kiley CNN, in Sumi Province.